Tom Sandoval called out for seemingly
lusting after Raquel Levis long before
scandival broke you're gonna enjoy
myself
yeah it all played out on the latest
episode of Vanderpump Rules filmed six
months before Tom and Raquel's Affair
came to light and now ET is running
through all the moments that had us
doing a double take like this one I
don't think it was really like a big
deal
they're just two single people that are
decent looking and like Mexico that like
just decided to make out Sandoval coming
to Raquel's defense against Katie
Maloney after Raquel made out with her
ex Tom Schwartz in Mexico
how did that situation change how you
feel about Raquel oh my opinion ever
couldn't be lower then there's Lisa
Vanderpump's chat with both Toms at sir
why do you like it so much
yeah Lisa seemed to notice how giddy
Sandoval was around Raquel who he's also
fiercely protective of
I mean I don't appreciate being called
I'm being slight shamed for making out
with somebody like that's not cool yeah
I don't think it is either I definitely
want her to know what people are saying
about her I feel like Raquel doesn't
have a lot of people in her corner and
she's a really sweet girl she doesn't
have a bad bone in her body it's always
been about a group of people that's so
inextricably entwined and love each
other but also so volatile and then
Vanderpump Rules his very own deep
throat moment I'm scared though I kind
of started something last night James
Kennedy's girlfriend Ali Luber going
full Watergate revealing she witnessed a
late night dance sesh between Sandoval
and Raquel at a gay bar I saw Sandoval
and Raquel dancing together at the Abbey
after see you next Tuesday I thought it
was kind of weird it was like 1am and we
were like where's Ariana I personally
wouldn't be comfortable with it I guess
to have my boyfriend out at 1am with
girls that everyone's different that
info then comes up at Lala Kent's
birthday dinner after Raquel shows up
uninvited
[Music]
funny enemy
since you should not have showed up here
because
it doesn't like you get a lot of joy out
of that I don't get a lot of joy out of
it but like it's just funny to me and if
Sandoval can observe so can Katie you
get a lot of Toyota records
yeah
[Music]
what are you saying dude out of here man
yeah pump rules fans are no doubt
counting down the days till the reunion
where Andy Cohen sat down one on one
with Tom Raquel and Ariana Maddox there
was just so much on the table that
needed to be and everyone had things to
say I would say I mean that being said
I've now done you know hundreds of
reunions so yeah I would say this is
going to be this is going to be top ten
foreign